[Music]
and guilty until proven innocent news o
household no guilty until proven it's
like if they even have a hunch that's
already the fact submitted by Slick Rick
Oh Darla a man was cleared of rape
charges after our kite Facebook messages
proves his innocence oh it shows like
what he was doing when the supposed
grape went down no so this whole thing
during the trial they had Facebook
messages of the rape victim and then the
person that they're accusing but then it
turned out that these Facebook messages
were edited like they took out certain
messages like from the exchange that
made it seem like he was admitting to
who took him out it seems like it must
have been the girl she oh my god she
needs to go to war she does Photoshop
she's tampering with evidence I think
she's just photoshopped it out because
yeah I wasn't there but luckily this guy
his sister-in-law got into this Facebook
account and saw the real archived
message at the entire conversation ended
up clearing him he was he actually in
jail yeah this is like a whole ordeal it
was but they couldn't have done that
before that's a pretty easy yeah so the
cut that's what he's saying like this
dude he's just like you know why
couldn't the cops do their job right
like I've been sitting in jail like I've
been telling them I'm innocent and that
they could just look at my facebook but
they never did and then so not not until
his sister-in-law finally went in how
many years was he um so he was arrested
in 2012 Oh
oh my god that's [ __ ] weird isn't
gonna sue the city he should in 2012
hi I'm not too close bubbles so big and
it could have been way smaller
she got punished yeah yeah they're not
really clear an innocent man
punished I bet you got beat up what are
you in here for [ __ ] raper and then
you know they hate rapists in jail so
they rape all my understand what since
you'd like to take advantage of medicine
yeah that's why ok be a very awful turn
well he was innocent though yeah that's
not fair everyone's innocent in there
though wait so how come this evidence
wasn't presented in the beginning that's
the thing like what lawyers suck yeah
there's lawyers terrible they got the
budget one that's why you have like some
messages that were hidden from the jury
so apparently he said sorry at one point
the way they presented these messages it
seems like he was saying sorry for the
rape but in reality he was saying sorry
because he didn't text her back at some
some point in the conversations I feel
like oh sorry for that and then another
one was like they were talking about her
age and then she ends up saying like oh
so how old are you when she says 17 and
then for the jury he says oh me too but
in reality he says something like are
you single she's like yeah I'm and he
said me too
so things like that we're like now
they're making like he lied about his
age and I don't know it's just pretty
shady the way everything was was
presented to the jury but luckily now
she was found in so what was the girl's
motive to accuse him of rape did she get
her heart broken or something happened
this wasn't even a real relationship it
was a fling like they had just like
hooked up a couple times and like just
had like a very casual type of
relationship but it seemed like they
just stopped communicating and then he
got a new girlfriend he they went to
vacation out in Spain and then when he
got back this is six months after he
broke open with that fling he gets back
from Spain and he finds out that he's
being accused of rape damn do you think
she was like during the whole time we
were [ __ ] around you didn't even take
me to Mexico you took me to Burger King
and she gets to go to spray oh well this
does take place in the UK just so you
know like dude you took me to Nando's
you took me to hireling what the [ __ ]
you could have took me to Spain yeah I
know schmuck token he got arrested in
front of his new girlfriend and her
family in the airport damn damn he went
that hard dude hurt his his girlfriend
probably like oh [ __ ] I didn't believe
him but now look at that he gave up a
good man
who didn't rape that's so crazy yeah why
would someone do that that's also bad
for all the women right now with the
whole me twos and all that like that's
the reason why it's difficult for I
think law enforcement and people to
believe because there are cases where
people use this as an advantage and
indeed put guys innocent guys in prison
like that football player yeah yeah
ruined this whole [ __ ] life guy
didn't do [ __ ] and that girl said that
he raped him make her and then BOOM
whole life kind of [ __ ] for like ten odd
years or something and then she and
somebody recorded her I think it was
like her sister or something like we're
admitting that it was it wasn't real and
he got submitted and then he was free
and that dude was just bawling he was
supposed to be play pro he was he was
like on that track Wow like how much do
they owe that dude man
millions [ __ ] like that not only are
they're harming like his life but
they're also like [ __ ] it up for
everyone who really is a victim and then
like now they can't like now they have
like you people like this where they can
point to and say like we'll see like she
lied how do we know that you're not what
happens to you ladies Minds when you
hear something like this because they're
[ __ ] it up for everyone are you
violent seriously as to the bike like
why would you want to do that in the
first place like you're it's it's a
serious issue and it needs to be taken
seriously and like if you're I'm just
taking that to your advantage it's the
best fault it's really [ __ ] up because
I I think I might get put in a flame a
fire and hung for saying this but I'm
gonna say it anyway because I don't go
[ __ ] I think what should happen is if
you cry wolf and if you say that you
know someone raped it when they did it
because you just wanted to send them to
jail and all that stuff I think they
should get raped all right no no no
because I I mean like they probably
won't get hard but I think they like
randomly they should just get violent
violently raped somebody's life because
you you said that that's what happened
to you and it didn't to ruin somebody's
life so you should have that happen to
you so then you know what all the other
girls feel like you just [ __ ] it up
for all the women out there that really
got violently raped and then you use
that as an advantage to be fraudulent
should find the horniest homeless man to
do it the stinkiest one yeah cuz then
doctor that way that guy he's three
teeth yeah he's been having good
discipline and not raping people but
he's probably healthy but it needs how
the horny and then so you can kind of
let him get his jollies off and then she
can get a nightmare
and I think the trial should apply to
everything like if you try to frame yeah
its burglary or any of that stuff if
somebody's like if somebody's like hey
my neighbor's dog bit me now the dog has
to die whatever right but they really
bite them if he did invite them oh you
know what then we need to get five dogs
that have rabies and he needs to get bit
I just don't know what I think it's only
fair if you cry what if you lie if you
do those things whatever you lied about
should happen to you could you injustice
oh you just like sitting in jail and you
know you didn't do anything
and guess every day you wake up innocent
I would blow my [ __ ] brains out dude
he was also saying that like he he's
really disappointed in the system
obviously but also because he really
trusted that the system would work work
at the way out like clearly he was
telling the truth there's evidence in
the messages but apparently like somehow
they were just edited out and there's
just like he's just like wow I can't
believe that the police didn't
investigate properly and like you just
feel betrayed by the system it's cuz
they're stupid they don't know that
Photoshop exists apparently there was
this officer that obtained the messages
by asking the accuser to log onto her
Facebook and that apparently he stood
there and watched her print the whole
conversation so well that guy seriously
doesn't know technology at all he she
probably going to photoshop is that
Facebook yes it is maybe show me your
Facebook it's so scary oh this is so
crazy man when I hears things like this
it's like I picture myself in jail and
it's like I did it - yeah we kind of get
a small taste of what that feels like
every time I play mafia though like when
you really think about it cuz it's like
you know you're innocent you know what
you you know the part that you're
holding you know that's true and like
you're you're fighting for your life
like I'm innocent look and they're like
no I heard this and I saw that you why
did you react like this wise really
hears like no it's not
being I swear and like like imagine that
times like I'll just be like Josh
[ __ ] just put me away put me away the
og technique he was okay now I don't
know what's gonna happen to that girl
she needs to go to jail
well you said to a 12 right he that's
when he got arrested like late 2012 2013
but I don't know who what he wanted oh I
don't know when he got out I think she
should go to jail she's shot I she for
sure well if he should go to a guy jail
a horny homeless man's dessert want that
[ __ ] no some homeless guys are horny I
know they'd probably hook up with
homeless no that's true like I saw this
one couple they were just going to town
like it was homeless love like dating
they were so passionate they didn't care
anybody was around and then the dude
hasn't had his pants like down halfway
and his butt cheeks was showing and I
could just he didn't have a care in the
world he loved there was puppy love dude
yeah I've seen that before where there's
a guy and a girl like both homeless and
I standing outside of their tent and
then you know like sometimes the girls
TD's and she's not wearing a bra so you
know jesus [ __ ] sweeping around
inside of her shirt and then they both
got [ __ ] like smears on their face
he's grabbing her a nice but you could
tell it was like one of those flirting
stops and I was like dad's about to get
it on right now they love each that it's
straight-up lady in the trench
dude that that goes to show man no
matter what there's someone out there
for you they're smoking out of the same
crack pipe on different ends
Oh crazy especially yo look keep in mind
these are all a homeless people we're
talking about oh yeah yeah yeah we don't
discriminate it's just a la home cuz
that's all we know that's what we've
seen like in real we lived in downtown
we're not talking about the decent
homeless people we're just talking about
the crackheads
[Music]